ah you know I thought I was gonna get
away without doing a San Diego comic-con
video this year and then marbles showed
up okay I am NOT gonna spend time
addressing anything other than marble I
don't feel like doing a full rundown I
know some other trailers have dropped
lately it chapter two dropped the Harley
Quinn animated thing that trailer
dropped like find whatever I'm gonna
focus on Marvel because I feel like they
brought the most substance in terms of
stuff that we didn't already know about
or at least stuff that we didn't already
know about that I cared about there was
other stuff that went on at comic-con
that I either have less investment in or
didn't seem like as big a deal at least
to me so because I am lazy and it's late
when I'm recording this let's take a
look at the lineup and what we're
actually dealing with so we got a whole
bunch of release dates and some specific
films that are coming out on May 1st
2020 we have the Black Widow movie still
believed to be a prequel though exactly
where it falls on the timeline not
currently sure about that November 6
2020 the Eternals February 12th 2021
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings first time we're getting the full
title on that May 7th 2012 on Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of a madness
also first time we're getting subtitle
there November 5th 2021 Thor love and
thunder we also had a number of dates
into 2022
but to try and even guess at those
because we have two official titles
haven't been announced would involve
speculation that I honestly don't feel
like doing so I'm not gonna touch
underneath that and I am mostly gonna
speak on the film's but I will say dizzy
Plus premieres also announced fall
twenty twenty thousand and Winter
Soldier spring 2021 Wanda vision also
spring 2021 is Loki also the spring 2021
is what if they are bringing in a whole
lot of like notable voice voices from
the franchise up to this point for that
so that should be
seeing them fall 2021 is Hawkeye they
are really not mess around with the
Disney Plus and also the announcement
that blade will be back and played by
Marcia Lally which is good I was kind of
afraid that Marshall uh was you know
burned off in Luke Cage season one but
this is a very cool use that I think I
would like I don't want to presume
presume oh my her so I'll he's gonna do
more Herschel oddly is a very good actor
with a very good range but I don't think
he's gonna try and do what Wesley Snipes
did with the part I've a feeling he's
gonna go for a bit of a different angle
I'm gonna be really curious to see what
that is so absolutely down for that but
let's get into these specific announced
films the most the one that we actually
know the most about substance of leave
right now is the black widow one but
honestly until we see a trailer it's
hard to know too many of the details
like I said about timeline or a full
tone or vibe it's obviously gonna be
more of a spy thing I'll be interested
to see how grounded they go with it
because we haven't had a more grounded
Marvel movie possibly ever there is
always at least one major fantastical
element so it would be really cool to do
something really grounded in just
spy-ish
I guess the closest we came would have
been Winter Soldier but you know even
that one had a Nazi scientists brain in
computers from the 70s so you know and
and I'm not mocking any of it I just
think it'd be interesting to strip all
that down and go basic which is what I'm
kind of hoping that a black widow will
be Eternals I have absolutely no idea or
clue I will say this is something that
actually I started sinking in with me
lately supposedly we're gonna be getting
our first lgbtq+ character in the
Eternals and can I be honest about
something it's actually gonna bug me a
little bit if the first lgbtq+ you know
non non cisgender or non hetero major
character is gonna be some kind of alien
because the Eternals aren't humans that
will actually bug me because the
franchise's we go
too long to be pulling the you know
alien or otherworldly being as analog
for minority group thing like this many
films in just give me a human being give
me give me someone who who would have
gone through the experience of what it
is to be anything that is not cisgender
and heterosexual in the society we
currently live in
I'd really kind of prefer that at this
point I'm not gonna say no you know to a
queer character showing up in the
Eternals but the more I think about the
more it actually kind of annoys me that
that's the route they're gonna go for it
but you know we have to start somewhere
so I'll take it
so going on from that so Schanke and the
legend of the ten rings that time
they'll actually potentially a really
big deal because when you think Marvel
you think ten rings what do you think
you think the Mandarin now here's the
funny thing about that I never assuming
that that actually is what it indicates
at the very least is gonna be the return
of that criminal organization that we
haven't heard from like well I guess
since the Iron Man 3 and so that would
be you know at the bare minimum but it
wouldn't make sense to bring that back
if they're gonna do something but the
Mandarin and I never really thought they
were gonna do that now a lot of Marvel
fans thought that they would do
something with the Mandarin because we
had Iron Man 3 with the whole reveal of
Oh what you thought was the Mandarin
really isn't and it's all a big con and
then later in one of the wasps they were
called the one shots it was called hail
to the king it was implied that there
actually is a real Mandarin who is
ticked off that his name got dragged
through the mud for this ridiculous scam
here's the thing though and this is I
think one of those times or had been up
to this point one of those times that it
was kind of a disconnect between the
hardcore fans and the mainstream
audiences because hardcore fans always
took that as a thing of like oh that
means we're gonna get the real Mandarin
someday and I had always kind of soom
like gay folks that was just a bone they
they threw us because most mainstream
audiences you know
the one who acted the ones who actually
pushed these films into well now endgame
being the biggest money-making film of
all time
they didn't watch the one shot they
don't know there's a quote-unquote real
Mandarin and they don't care but I guess
they're actually gonna do something with
it which I'll be very curious to see how
they handle that knowing what the
Mandarin is like on the page and how
they character can and has been used as
some of these stereotyping that the
character can fall into they are they
are waiting into some heavy waters
between just shang-chi himself as a
character being you know from the
somewhat exploitative you know
influenced by the somewhat explorative
era of kung fu as a you know being a
thing you know as a genre you know kung
fu films and all that stuff he was very
much inspired out of that that's already
kind of potentially heavily laden with
stuff if you're not careful and add the
Mandarin to that um well you're uh
you're taking on a challenge I mean
props to your ambition I suppose but
I'll be really curious to see what that
what that ends up being so Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness now
this thing all right every single time
this sort of thing comes up people tell
me Oh see you were wrong they are gonna
do a multiverse cuz I have K I've said
well I've said most embedded that I
don't ever want them to do a multiverse
and that I don't think they will now
people will rub my nose in this but
here's the thing Doctor Strange already
did a multiverse and the multiverse that
Doctor Strange does is not what I am
saying they should never do because the
multiverse that Doctor Strange does is
completely different planes of existence
you know when you get into things like
the quantum around the mirror universe
the the dark universe and who knows what
kind of trippy stuff we're going to be
getting in this that's not what I'm
talking about the multiverse I don't
ever want to see is the parallel
universe thing where it's like here's
earth as you know with the characters
you know except their gender swapped
except they're all pirates except
they're zombies for some stupid reason
that people think should would make a
good movie but it would be friggin
terror
so you know that's what I never want to
see the kind of multiverse stuff that
dr. strange is already done I'm so down
for it especially because I really want
to see how creative they can get with it
they've got fairly creative in the first
one but I want to see them go all on I
want to see them go nuts I want to see
them go trippy and the director is
saying that he wants to take in the
direction of making a legitimately scary
Marvel movie and I do kind of want to
see what that looks like
not gonna lie so that then of course
brings us to the big headline with Thor
love and thunder
first of all Tyco ITT's back so we're
gonna get the lighter tone but also we
have Jane Foster
returning which means Natalie Portman is
back and they do appear to be doing the
storyline where Jane Foster wheels me on
there and takes on the mantle of Thor
now I have very mixed feelings about
this so I have actually read the first
volume of the goddess of thunder line I
read the the trade collected trade of
that actually Liz and I read that
together and we reviewed it on our
podcast stuff like a girl over on the
fire and water podcast network whoo-hoo
plug in my stuff that is somewhere other
than this channel but we both liked it
pretty well we had little niggling
complaints here and there but for the
most part we both enjoyed it and I and
what more I've seen about that character
and the way it was done I actually do
kind of like it I think there's a lot of
potential in it and a lot that can be
done with it
my reservation is with Natalie Portman
specifically not because she's a bad
actress I actually think when she's
passionate about the work Natalie
Portman is fantastic but that's the
thing she needs to be passionate about
what it is she is doing and her
performances in these films especially
then Thor the dark world she did not
seem like she really wanted to be there
like there were a handful of actors in
the first you know kind of wave of these
films who they were there because their
agent told them it was gonna be a good
idea and Natalie Portman was one
Christopher Eccleston was another you
know
you ibly Hugo Weaving you know he just
had actors who you could tell they
weren't passionate about this story they
just thought it'd be good for their
resume or their agent talked them into
it now
as the franchise went on and got so big
yeah different people wanted in but and
they didn't have to convince people to
come in on these things nearly as much
anymore but I was never shocked that we
hadn't seen Natalie Portman again cuz I
really just got the feeling she didn't
want to play in this playground so her
coming back makes me nervous because I
know that if they can find an angle that
she actually is excited about and goes
all-in on her performance the way that
she can do when she cares it could be
really good but I've already seen her
kind of you know be serviceable and not
try to be more than that in this role
already so that that makes me nervous as
far as the story itself goes it'll be
interesting to see because Thor is not
in the same state he is now that he was
in the comics when this happened so oh
boy I'm not gonna go through the whole
background of everything but basically
in the comics Thor who started going by
Odin son to distinguish him from Thor
female Thor who was actually wielding
Mjolnir he had actually become unworthy
he couldn't lift the hammer anymore and
then Jane and actually initially we
didn't even know who was we just knew
that a woman was wielding the hammer I
mean it wouldn't be revealed to be Jane
Foster until sometime later I hear
they're probably gonna reveal it right
off the bat because it's like and anyone
who reads the comics knows who that
that's who it is it's not worth trying
to do it as a as a reveal or anything
but you know he was he was in a state of
disgrace in a lot of ways and one could
argue he kind of is in the movies cuz
like as guards gone and he's kind of you
know lost you know he he obviously went
through hell and following infinity war
but he's not really in the same place as
a character as he was in the comics so
it's gonna be interesting to see how he
reacts somebody
just taking up his mantle because I
don't think it's gonna be a delight
direct parallel to how it was done in
the comics which honestly shouldn't even
need to be pointed out anymore when it
comes to Marvel because they almost
never just transport over the story they
take a title or maybe a core concept and
then very much do their own thing if you
ever read civil war versus watching
Civil War not the same experience at all
and other times they'll just pull a
title and leave it at that and have
nothing to do in source material so I'm
pretty sure they're just taking this
concept and especially someone like
Tycho OTT who seems to have a bit of a
more free flow vibe to what he does I'm
sure we're gonna end up with something
that is not just a direct translation
from the comic so I'm very curious about
it I hope it's good but just you gotta
show me that Natalie Portman cares
because I felt like definitely the last
time and a bit the first time that she
appeared in this part it felt like she
didn't and it didn't ruin either of
those movies or at least you know wasn't
necessarily the biggest issue with
either of those movies but yeah I'm
nervous I think that's everything I
wanted to cover as far as the Marvel
stuff goes I wanted to build up to the
Thor thing because it was getting the
most thing but what do you think about
any of these announcements or whatever
one I inevitably missed because I always
forget to talk about something I think
it's the first thing that gets left in
the comments so go ahead drop them down
the comments and let's talk about it
there's a whole bunch of stuff to do as
well there's the like button there's a
subscribe you could share this with a
friend I'd appreciate that as well I
have a patreon if you wish to support
this channel to help me cover my bills
and a whole bunch of other links besides
give them a click they take you places
but also you don't have to because at
the end of the day folks here at the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]